foreign
[Music]
can do nothing to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
[Music]
a lot has changed in the last few years
a wizard gave me superpowers
and then everybody got superpowers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
and stole the power of the Gods he
ripped it from our father's call okay
maybe I should be writing all this down
your world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
all right
we have one job to do save the world
finally
stop
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
I speak Millennial
searching for worthy champion
exactly what must be done
Billy what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
yeah we do
start in front of platinum now we're
here
foreign
[Music]